with that Mr Crumbley is there anything
you would like to State before I pass
sentence you make may he stand yes he
may thank you may
proceed um I like to thank you for
letting me speak your honor um you're
all here because of me
today what I
did my actions were because of what I
chose to do I could not stop myself but
I am the one who led to why we are here
today I do not diminish any ability to
anyone who could have stopped me of
anyone of a school or parents they did
not know and I did not tell them what I
plan to do so they are not at fault what
I've
done I am a really bad person I have
done terrible things that no one should
ever do I have
lied been not trustworthy I've hurt many
people and that's what I've done and I'm
not denying it but that's not who I plan
on to be whatever sentence it is I do
plan to be better than I am I don't know
if you'll believe that but records in 15
20 25 years can show that I will change
because it may not show it now if only
two years of Records but I am trying and
all I want is for the people I hurt to
just have a final sense of culpability
that justice has somewhat been served in
any F capacity that they can recognize
it with um any sentence that they ask
for I ask that you do impose it on me
because I want them to be happy and I
want them to feel secure and safe and I
do not want them to worry another day
because I really am sorry for what I've
done for what I've taken of them
I cannot give it back but I can try my
best in the future to help other people
and that is what I will do so thank you
thank
you with that this court has listened to
extensive evidence in this case I heard
four days of testimony from the Miller
hearing I've presided over numerous
placements hearings I conducted the
initial placement Hearing in this case
and so the court is fully aware of the
defendant's upbringing I'm fully aware
of the circumstances that brought him
before the
courts first to the victims of the
deceased the court sends out its sincer
condolences to their family to the
injured victims and to those victims as
relates to count one terrorism causing
death thank you for your courage and
strength in speaking today as well as
sending written corresponden as Council
has pointed out the court has read
everything that you've submitted I've
read the defendant sens memorandum I've
read The People's response there too
I've read all of the exhibits that were
attached and I've read every single
Victim Impact statement over the course
of three days probably took took me
closer to 36 hours to read all of this
and so I've read everything and have
gone back through the complete
file the the letters truly gave the
court a sliver of insight into the
unique amazing personalities of Justin
Hana Tate Madison the court cannot begin
to imagine the fear that the parents of
those students at Oxford High School had
on November 30th 2021 I cannot even
begin to Fathom to have to wait and
meire to see if your loved one would
return is
heart-wrenching and that's true
Terror and not to have your loved one
show up atmire the court could not
imagine the pain I know that whatever
sentence the court imposes will not
bring your loved one back or cure the
mental anguish or lifelong physical
scars that some of you have but I hope
that this sentence does allow you to
close one chapter in your life
I also want to thank law enforcement
that responded that day because I know
this has not been easy on them as
well as previously stated the court has
read defendant sentencing memorandum and
the people's response again defense
argues that defendant should receive a
term of years because of defend alleged
mental illness defendant site people
versus Bennett 335 Mish
40902 excuse me 2021 case the court
notes that it is not say because the
defendant may be mentally ill that that
automatically means he's erably corrupt
what the court notes is that he has an
obsession with
violence that this act involved
extensive planning extensive
research and he executed on every last
one of the things that he
planned as the court stated in his
written opinion in order regarding the
Miller hearing defendant's alleged
mental illness did not interfere with
his ability to extensively planned for
months his actions nor did it interfere
with his ability to execute those plans
this started with him asking for a
better gun to conduct the school
shooting he had initially a 22 caliber
weapon that he wrote would not do enough
damage and so weeks and weeks prior to
this offense he started to formulate
this plan and knew and asked for the
weapon that he could cause the most harm
with as council is aware the goals of
sentencing do not only involve
Rehabilitation but also involve
deterrence and Punishment deterrence is
two parts it's private deterrence for
the defendant and hopes that they would
never commit an act like this again but
then there's also public
deterrence where the public sees the
punishment that the individual has
received and hopes that the public will
never do anything like this in the
future the court has read the report
from gu post Solutions was very
lengthy respectfully the court does not
find this report to be mitigating in
this case the report simply points the
finger at Axford Public Schools while
the court agrees that more possibly
could have been done that issue was not
properly before this
court we are here for sentencing based
upon the defendant actions not the
alleged shortcomings of others as the
defendant pointed out himself he took
responsibility and he himself is not
asking this court for a turn of years
the court cannot underscore defendant
extense of planning and execution in
this case enough he practiced shooting
at a gun range
he practiced racking and unracking the
gun and on November 30th 2021 he could
have chosen not to conduct the school
shooting when his parents were called to
the school on that morning for his
drawings he could have said something
then he had a gun in his backpack at
that time when the school counselor
advised the parents to please get him
help within the next 48
hours he could have stopped then and
simply accepted the help that was going
to be offered for him because according
to the reports his mother said that he
she'd get him the
help he could have changed his mind
unfortunately after shooting the first
person Phoebe Arthur he could have
changed his mind at that
point but he
didn't he continued to walk through the
school picking and choosing who was
going to
die as the defendant said in his own
words this is nobody fought but his own
he stated this afternoon that with help
that probably would not have stopped him
that is absolutely concerning to this
court the court apologized to the victim
for the
bluntness but defendant shot and killed
Justin Schilling at Point Blank Range
after having him get down on his knees
in front of another
student he shot who was already shot
once before he walked up to her to
finish the job by shooting her
again that is an execution that is
torture he shot most people multiple
times and as he wrote he did this for
notoriety and he wanted to go down in
history as the biggest school shooter in
Michigan
history the court cannot ignore the Deep
trauma defendant caus to the state of
Michigan but in particular the Oxford
Community Court simply cannot ignore
that the court notes that teachers and
students returned to Oxford High School
after this tragic event the court cannot
even fathom or imagine walking through
the halls of that school knowing that
your fellow student your friend your
classmate was killed in a restroom or in
the
hallway
most if not all of the letters that I
read advised the court that there are a
significant number of people in Oxford
that now have
PTSD that now have survivors guilt and
deep depression that arose from this
incident defendant actions clearly
created a new normal for all of the
individuals involved and all of those
indirectly impacted as
well unfortunately this is what the
defend
wanted as he wrote in his journal he
wanted to see the impact of his crime
which is why he did not take his own
life again this goes back to the
defendant's extensive
planning he chose not to die on that day
because he wanted the
notoriety the terror that he caused in
the state of Michigan and in Oxford is a
true Act of
terrorism
respectfully defendant is the rare
juvenile before this
court the court having read the PSI and
being fully familiar but before I get
that I will also note that Council
brought up an issue of making bombs for
Hitler the court that does not change
the Court's opinion about the defendant
obsession with violence I thank Miss hot
for bringing that to my attention but it
still does not change the Court's
opinion about him being obsessed with
violence because his obsession was also
outlined in the websites that he visited
his obsession was also outlined in his
extensive drawings of violence and his
obsession continued as I noted in the
Court's opinion and Order even while he
was in the Oakland County
Jail with that the court having read the
PSI and being fully familiar with the
defendant and the underlying facts of
this case believes that it is in the
best interest of justice as well as
proportionate to the needs of this case
case to sentence defendant as
follows as it relates to Doc 2022
27956 FC count one terrorism causing
death sentences of the court is that
defendant Shall Serve life without the
possibility of parole credit for eight
days served counts two through five
homicide first degree premeditated
murder juvenile defendant sence of the
court is that defendant Shall Serve the
rest of his life without the possibility
of parole with the Michigan Department
of Corrections credit for eight days
served on counts
six through 12 assault with intent to
murder on each of the counts defendant
is sentenced to 18 years and nine months
to 80 years with the Michigan Department
of Corrections credit for eight days
served on counts 13 through 24 those
being felony firearm defendant is
sentenced to two years with the Michigan
Department of Corrections on each of
those counts counts with credit for 730
days
served counts 1 through 12 are
concurrent to each other and counts 13
through 24 are concurrent to each other
count one is consecutive to count 13
count two is consecutive to count 14
count three is consecutive to count 15
count four is consecutive to count 16
count five is consecutive to count 17
count six is consecutive to count 18
count seven is consecutive to count 19
count eight is consecutive to count 20
count nine is consecutive to count 21
count 10 is consecutive to count 22
count 11 is consecutive to 23 and count
12 is consecutive to count 24 all of
those consecutive counts are by reason
of the felony firearm statute is there a
challenge to restitution here there is
not your honor thank you restitution
will be set in the amount of
$2,781 State cost will be set in the
amount of
$1,632 you are not to have any contact
with Oxford High School or enter any
excuse me enter Oxford High School
you're not to have any contact
whatsoever with families of Madison
Baldwin Tate Meyer Hanah St Juliana and
Justin Schilling also you are not to
have any contact with the following
victims or their families that being
phie Arthur John oo Molly Darnell Riley
France Elijah Mueller Kylie O Aiden
Watson and Keegan
Gregory and I will note that restitution
is payable to the Crime Victims right
Compensation Program with that Michigan
Department of Corrections did I miss
anything asked the court to order 130
Prime victims fee $60 DNA cost of DNA
test thank you DNA cost $60 Prime
victim's right P at $130 did I miss
anything else DNA testing your honor DNA
testing is here by order thank
you with that M Crumbley you are
entitled to file an application for
leave to appeal if you are financially
unable to retain a lawyer the court will
appoint a order to represent you on
appeal the request for a lawyer must be
filed within 42 days after sentencing
your attorney is going to be handing you
an appet rights form sir do you
acknowledge receipt of the appet rights
form your honor I have um tendered that
to my client has signed it and I will
tender it to the court thank you very
much with that Council anything else for
the record not for the people thank you
nothing from defense thank you very much
thank you very much with that deputies
you may take Mr TR to those in the
gallery please be seated until he is
exited